[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis son démarrage le 27 décembre
dernier la campagne de vaccination
contre la covid 19 divise pour certains
il faut vacciner la population entière
ce serait la seule solution face à
l'épidémie pour d'autres le vaccin est
plus dangereux que la pandémie elle-même
et les discours les plus extrêmes
s'affichent sur les réseaux sociaux
le virement
[Musique]
youtuber conférencier ou médecin
septique ces influenceurs ont fait des
vaccins un pilier de leur rhétorique
mais au-delà des antivax c'est toute une
frange de la population qui hésite une
série de crises politico sanitaires
comme celle des vaccins contre
l'hépatite B contre la rougeole ou la
grippe H1N1 ont été rodé la confiance
des Français en avril 2021 44% des
Français n'avaient toujours pas
l'intention de se faire vacciner contre
la covid-19 et pourtant les sites de
réservation pour recevoir la première
dose du vaccin sont saturé
cette pandémie est donc un
extraordinaire révélateur de la relation
passionnelle et complexe qui unit les
Français à la vaccination pour la
comprendre il faut remonter le temps et
prendre la direction d'Arbois dans le
Jura
c'est ici que Louis Pasteur met au point
son vaccin contre la rage
le petit Joseph Meister mord du 14 fois
par un chien enragé est le premier
patient à être vacciné en 1885
il survit ce succès médical est célébré
par la presse et l'opinion publique
Louis Pasteur devient l'icône du savant
populaire
cependant cette poisse scientifique
était déjà à l'époque loin de faire
l'unanimité
elle suscite des interrogations voire
même des accusations
on en trouve des traces dans la maison
familiale du chercheur
ce lieu qui lui servait aussi de
laboratoire d'été est devenu un musée ou
des documents précieusement conservés
témoignent de l'ampleur de la
controverse
[Musique]
entre deux expériences Louis Pasteur
avait pour habitude de lire et découper
soigneusement les articles de ces
contradicteurs il les collait dans des
carnets qui ont été découverts récemment
par la virologue Françoise Salvadori et
l'historien laurent-henri Vignot alors
les carnets de pasteurs les traductions
des articles qui étaient publiés en
allemand ou italien actuellement alors
ça c'est pas les bons là en revanche il
y a quelque chose d'intéressant qui est
une revue italienne scientifique la
revue clinique est thérapeutique
italienne et là on trouve quand même
quelque chose de très violent puisque
l'italien lui dit voilà la réponse à
votre insolence insensée vous êtes
devenu le docteur Ferrand de la rage
vous avez jeté dans la boule à Sciences
françaises mais soyez bien sûr qu'ici à
Naples on écrasera votre impudent
charlatanisme donc voilà un exemple qui
dépasse un peu quand même la simple
critique scientifique et qui montre que
les opposants à Pasteur pouvaient être
parfois violents y compris au niveau
international
ce qu'on trouve dans les carnets c'est
quand même de la science beaucoup plus
enfin la pratique normale de la science
avec les controverses sur des protocoles
par exemple donc là on voit le carnet de
traduction de des travaux de Monsieur
phone Frisch un Autrichien parce que
pasteur faisait traduire donc les
résultats de ces correspondants de
langue étrangères et il écrivait en
marche ce qu'il en pensait et finalement
il conclut en disant c'est encore
impossible quoi que maintenant plus
rapproché de la vérité donc c'est bien
un peu le style pastorien qui s'adresse
on sait pas trop à qui dans ces carnets
sans doute à lui-même pour se prouver
qu'il a raison finalement vis-à-vis des
autres qui sont encore une fois dans une
controverse scientifique relativement
classique
[Musique]
pasteur consignait ses réflexions sur
les polémiques vaccinales dans des
cahiers car à la fin du 19e siècle dans
l'imaginaire collectif l'idée d'inoculer
le mal pour soigner le mal fait peur et
paraît contre nature
[Musique]
dans certains journaux satiriques de
l'époque tenus par ce qu'on appelle
alors les Antilles vaccinateurs on
hésite même pas à représenter le
pastorisme comme une médecine qui au
lieu de soigner fait des victimes
[Musique]
alors il y a un choix de caricature sur
pasteur qui est vraiment énorme et qui
finalement illustre les différents
opinions qui représentaient une
véritable attaque à dominaine contre
pasteur on le croque volontiers avec une
grosse tête comme on le voit ici une
tête totalement disproportionnée on
commence à voir pointer un peu d'ironie
sur son côté un peu orgueilleux on le
montre avec des animaux qui torturent
plus ou moins donc on voit apparaître
ces petits chiens qui bavent et donc
bien sûr on veut nous montrer que cette
découverte s'est faite au détriment d'un
certain nombre d'animaux et on suggère
que il a sa doute tué beaucoup de lapins
et beaucoup de chiens on lui reproche
également finalement de d'empoisonner
tout le monde puisque cette ces images
de grosses seringues c'est quand même
finalement derrière tout ça ce qu'on
entend c'est l'empoisonnement
d'une certaine façon on peut dire que le
mouvement anti-vaccin autant de pasteur
était autant un mouvement contre pasteur
qu'un mouvement contre les vaccins
malgré ces détracteurs et quelques
échecs Louis Pasteur poursuit ses
recherches sur les maladies infectieuses
avec le soutien de l'Académie des
sciences il collecte des fonds et lance
une souscription internationale grâce à
cet argent ils fonde l’institut pasteur
le 14 novembre 1888 le combat des
antivacs prend alors un nouvel angle
d'attaque le soupçon d'enrichissement
personnel et de spéculation sur le dos
des malades
dans cette grande boîte verte pasteur
gardait des papiers qu'il jugeaient
forcément important et il est
intéressant de voir que parmi les
documents qu'il a jugé important il y a
ce compte-rendu de séance du Conseil
Municipal de Paris dans lequel le
docteur katio qui était un élu
républicain et connu pour être très
anticlérical et aussi très antipastorien
s'oppose à la construction de l'Institut
Pasteur en demandant de au conseil
municipal de revenir sur son vote pour
que cette institut ne soit pas
construit
les détracteurs de pasteurs ne sont pas
seulement des scientifiques
dans le journal L'Intransigeant le
journaliste et polémiste Henri Rochefort
l'écrivain le plus populaire de France à
cette époque accuse régulièrement
pasteur de ne cherchez en développant la
vaccination qu'à s'enrichir
[Musique]
on Rochefort un personnage qui
politiquement est passé de la commune au
boulangerisme mais qui a toujours été
très antipastorien et ce passé pas de
numéro sans que on rappelle que Monsieur
pasteur avait une pension de 25000
francs qui lui était versé par l'état
français et que pour un empoisonneur
c'était quand même beaucoup
cette tendance à vouloir accuser
monsieur pasteur de gagner de l'argent
et vraiment à mettre en lien avec ce qui
se passe actuellement puisque je ne sais
pas si on peut vraiment dire que c'est
le début de Big Pharma mais en tout cas
ce soupçon d'enrichissement a commencé
même sans doute avant pasteur avec les
premiers médecins inoculateurs au 18e
siècle a pris un nouveau tournant
justement avec la le début
d'industrialisation si on peut dire de
la production des vaccins juste avec
l'Institut Pasteur et la personnalité de
pasteur a commencé de cristalliser des
doutes sur cette enrichissement
potentiel puisque ça sa pension était
constamment remise au centre des débats
depuis le 19ème siècle cette accusation
de recherche de profit par les
fabricants de vaccins n'a jamais cessé
le terme Big Pharma traduit cette
hostilité envers l'industrie
pharmaceutique dont le souci principal
ne serait pas la santé mais la
rentabilité à tout prix
[Musique]
pourtant tout au long du 20e siècle les
vaccins constituent une avancée majeure
de la médecine et sauve les vies de
millions de personnes contre les
maladies infectieuses actuellement
20% de Français sont menacés de
tuberculose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans tous les milieux on multiplie les
opérations de dépistage songer que sur
un millier d'individus de 15 à 40 ans
850 au moins sont destinées à être
touchés par l'infection plus de 200
seront gravement atteints sans amour
rond chiffre qui donne le vertige
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autre maladie infectieuse la variole qui
fait des ravages au début du 20e siècle
alors en 1902 devant l'épreuve
d'efficacité du vaccin le gouvernement
français décide de le rendre obligatoire
une première
et c'est un succès les Français se
précipitent pour se faire vacciner
au fil des années l'obligation vaccinale
s'étend la diphtérie
le tétanos
le BCG puis la polio au début des années
60 la vaccination se répand jusqu'au
cœur des villages après l'Amérique
l'Europe adopte la vaccination contre la
podiumyélite en France c'est la petite
commune savoyarde de bellandre qui a eu
les honneurs de la première vaccination
massive tous les enfants et les jeunes
gens soient presque la moitié de la
population du village ont reçu une dose
de vaccin mise au point par l'Institut
Pasteur
mais cette série d'obligations nourrit
peu à peu le feu de la contestation en
1954 est fondée la Ligue nationale pour
la liberté des vaccinations qui
deviendra la principale association
anti-vaccin de France
[Musique]
ses fondateurs se présentent comme les
défenseurs des libertés individuelles
alors la tension entre sécurité
collective et liberté individuelle est
une problématique constante lorsqu'on
parle de vaccination est-ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que dès le départ on
avait des médecins très récalcitrants
vis-à-vis de notre ongleta et quand on
regarde dans les archives notamment de
l'Académie de médecine toutes ces
discussions autour de l'obligation
vaccinale on retrouve énormément de
discours autour de l'autorité du père de
famille également donc il y a une vision
très patriarcale au départ qui est perçu
comme une intrusion dans la vie privée
des individus donc cette question des
libertés individuelles et en fait
consubstantielle des mouvements
anti-vaccinaux en France
malgré ses oppositions la vaccination se
poursuit 10 ans après l'obligation du
vaccin contre la polio la maladie a
quasiment disparu en France
mais c'est en 1980 que la vaccination
connaît l'un de ses plus beaux succès
l'OMS annonce l'éradication complète de
la variole dans le monde
le danger des maladies infectieuses
semble s'éloigner alors dans les années
80 les contraintes se relâchent
l'intérêt collectif et la santé publique
s'effacent devant la soif de bien-être
individuel
[Musique]
de nouveau vaccins sont développés et
commercialisés comme les vaccins contre
la rougeole les oreillons et la rubéole
l'état préfère les recommandés plutôt
que de les rendre obligatoire
mais en 2011 le réveil est brutal
l'agence régionale de santé veut
relancer la vaccination contre la
rougeole l'épidémie de retour alors
qu'on la croyait disparu mais depuis
quelques mois les cas sont en
recrudescence la rougeole que l'on
pensait presque éteinte resurgit et la
France est le pays européen le plus
touché cette année-là près de 15000
français sont contaminés et 6 en meurent
95% d'entre eux ne sont pas vaccinés
principalement des enfants
Lucie Guimier a cherché à savoir d'où
venait les principaux foyers épidémiques
elle a interviewé plus de 300 par an
pour essayer de comprendre comment une
telle épidémie a pu se diffuser j'ai
cartographié donc le départ de
l'épidémie à partir de 2008 et son
inscription territoriale jusqu'à
2011-2012 donc elle s'est propagée du
fait de faible taux de couverture
vaccinale dans certaines poches de
population on sait qu'il y a des milieux
plutôt religieux des milieux
philosophiques ou des milieux
complotistes donc certains milieux très
marqués par certaines idéologies qui
sont réfractaires à la vaccination et
qui de fait sont potentiellement des
foyers pour des épidémies de rougeole
aux épidémies de coqueluche
cette carte montre l'évolution de
l'épidémie de rougeole entre 2008 et
2011 les travaux de Lucie Guimier ont
mis en évidence l'origine de l'épidémie
la rougeole s'est diffusée à partir de
deux foyers très différents mais qui ont
pour point commun d'être des communautés
qui s'affichent antivaxin
le premier de ces foyers antivax est le
mouvement anthroposophe créé par
Rudolphe Steiner en 1912 ces adeptes
voient dans la vaccination une
interférence dans le processus naturel
du développement de l'enfant le taux de
vaccination y est donc particulièrement
bas le mouvement anthroposophe est très
implanté en Alsace et dans le sud-est
deux régions touchées par l'épidémie de
rougeole dès 2008 autre univers anti-vax
ou s'est propager l'épidémie la
fraternité s'impidis société de prêtres
intégriste fondée par Monseigneur
Lefebvre ainsi les villes de
Camblain-l'Abbé dans le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais et puis en Auxois en
Bourgogne ont été deux autres de ses
foyers épidémiques on y trouve justement
des écoles tenues par cette fraternité
aujourd'hui les positions anti-vacs de
ce mouvement religieux n'ont pas évolué
comme en témoigne cette vidéo récente
filmée et diffusée en pleine épidémie de
covid
donc nous nous trouvons bien la grande
question nous dit le journaliste à ce
stade est donc de savoir quel remède va
l'emporter autrement dit elles se sont
se les mondialistes avec leur implants
et leurs vaccins ou tout simplement les
hommes de bon sens les patriotes les
gens qui aiment l'humanité tout
simplement un vaccin développé à la hâte
qui pourrait en fait aggraver les effets
de la maladie chez ceux qui le
contractent et rappelons-nous justement
que le diable n'est pas seulement
menteur le diable est homicide est
important de se rappeler que le diable
tue alors il a fait son travail à
l'occasion de Vatican 2 en répandant
l'erreur et la confusion dans l'esprit
des catholiques et désormais il veut
tuer non seulement les esprits mais
aussi donc les corps pendant très
longtemps en fait les questions morales
et les questions religieuses ont été
pensées de manière très intriquée avec
les questions de santé et donc comme ces
arguments ont été présents dès le 19e
siècle c'est le cas de la France on
retrouve des arguments qui sont assez
similaires mais finalement qui perdent
leur connotation religieuse et on voit
par exemple l'idée que le corps est un
temple et qu'il faut respecter la nature
donc l'idée de nature naturisme de
manière à remplacer des religieuses dans
la critique vaccinale des dernières
décennies
mais celui qui a le plus contribué à
laisser penser aux parents que le vaccin
pouvait être plus dangereux que la
maladie elle-même et semer le doute
quant au vaccin contre la rougeole les
oreillons et la rubéole du vaccin ROR
c'est cet homme Andrew Wakefield ce
médecin britannique publie une étude en
1998 dans la revue médicale de référence
the landset
il dit avoir trouvé un lien de cause à
effet entre 12 cas d'enfants autistes et
le vaccin
cette étude fait l'effet d'une bombe
dans les médias et l'opinion publique
pourtant en 2010 the landset retire
l'article de son site
suite à une enquête la revue découvre
que les résultats avaient été falsifiés
volontairement des parents d'enfants
autistes avaient financé l'étude en
espérant gagner des indemnisations à
l'issue d'un procès contre les
fabricants du vaccin
ces révélations ne découragent pas
Andrew wakfield réfugiés au Texas il
produit en 2016 le film vaxt un
plaidoyer anti-vaccin aujourd'hui encore
il est une figure active et influente de
la combosphère
l'ex-président américain Donald Trump et
brun proche de Wakefield et a longtemps
relayé ses théories sur Twitter
[Musique]
au Royaume-Uni les conséquences de la
faire Wakefield sur la vaccination sont
dévastatrices entre 1996 et 2002 le taux
de vaccination au RER passe de plus de
90% à moins de 60 % dans des régions
comme celle de Londres
en France les arguments de Wakefield
mettent plus de temps à se diffuser
on a vu des chutes des couvertures
vaccinales des résurgences de rougeole
quand moi j'ai étudié les mouvements
anti-vaccins en France à l'époque sur la
rougeole c'était pas un argument qui
était très très cité par les parents
mais je pense que ce ces arguments ils
ont pénétré les discours du fait d'une
médiatisation au fil des années vraiment
croissantes au Royaume-Uni aux
États-Unis et qui a pénétré petit à
petit les milieux anti-vaccins français
conséquence la couverture vaccinale
contre la rougeole ne suffit toujours
pas même après l'électrochoc que
provoque l'épidémie de 2011 en 2017 une
nouvelle fois la France fait face à une
flambée de rougeole la ministre de la
Santé Agnès Buzyn et Édouard Philippe
Premier ministre décide alors d'étendre
l'obligation vaccinale
des maladies que l'on croyait éradiquer
se développent à nouveau sur notre
territoire
des enfants meurent de la rougeole
aujourd'hui en France dans la patrie de
pasteurs ce n'est pas admissible l'an
prochain les vaccins pour la petite
enfance qui sont unanimement recommandés
par les autorités de santé deviendront
obligatoires
depuis cette décision les parents
doivent vacciner leurs enfants contre 11
maladies pour être inscrits en crèche ou
accepté à l'école les carnets de
vaccination sont désormais inspectés
mais certains parents trouvent la mesure
disproportionnée et manifeste leur
mécontentement je pense pas qu'on va
vacciner nos enfants contre 11 maladies
je pense que c'est insensé
face à la crise vaccinale il a été en
effet décidé d’étendre dans certains
pays ça a été le cas en France ça a été
le cas si en Italie d'étendre
l'obligation vaccinale notamment chez
les enfants et ce qu'on craignait c'est
que ça en fait entraîne une forme de
crise de ce qu'on appelle le paternisme
médical c'est à dire que ça mette les
gens dans une situation de sujet passif
et donc de résistance et en vérité c'est
pas tout à fait ça qu'on a observé même
ça pouvait être des hypothèses sur
lesquelles on travaillait on a plutôt
observé une bonne adhésion à ces mesures
d'extension de la vaccination
obligatoire en France
effectivement depuis 2018 la couverture
vaccinale des enfants est passée au-delà
des 90%. pourtant certains parents ont
trouvé la parade sur certains sites
internet ils échangent conseils et
adressent pour falsifier les carnets de
vaccination en s'appuyant sur des
médecins complaisants
[Musique]
mais pour Jérémy World il faut faire
attention à bien distinguer les inquiets
des antivaxes il faut vraiment faire
très attention à ce terme anti-vaccin
qui a été le terme qu'on a
principalement utilisé pendant des
décennies pour comprendre toute forme de
doutes vis-à-vis des vaccins et on en
est vraiment revenu ça fait bientôt 10
ans que le terme qui s'impose dans les
milieux de recherche et puis tout le
terme d'hésitation vaccinale et on fait
vraiment la distinction voire même
l'opposition entre une toute petite
minorité de gens qui ont qui sont très
convaincu sur le sujet de la vaccination
en général qui refuse toute forme de
vaccination ça va être les personnes
justement qui remettent en cause
l'efficacité de la vaccination dans la
lutte contre les maladies sur les deux
derniers siècles etc ça touche une toute
petite proportion de la population
allait généralement estimée suivant les
études à entre deux et quatre pour cent
de la population ce qui est très faible
et
tout le reste de la palette des
attitudes qui existent qui peuvent aller
de d'avoir un doute un peu diffus on a
on se pose des questions allant jusqu'à
refuser certains vaccins mais pas
d'autres par exemple en France on a eu
beaucoup de débats autour de l'aluminium
vous avez beaucoup de personnes qui
disent moi je veux bien les vaccins mais
à condition qu'il y a pas d'aluminium
dedans jusqu'à peut-être beaucoup de
personnes qui se font vacciner mais tout
en ayant des doutes donc décaler un
vaccin douter se faire vacciner cibler
tout ça c'est une palette qui est
beaucoup plus large et qui en fait
touche une grande partie de la
population puisque là à nouveau suivant
les les études on peut avoir jusqu'à la
moitié de la moitié de la population qui
n'accepte pas sans se poser des
questions ceux qui se posent des
questions ceux qui doutent ce sont eux
que les antivacs cherchent à convaincre
la plupart du temps le prosélytisme se
fait en ligne les réseaux sociaux sont
devenus un immense champ de bataille où
les fausses informations servent de
munitions pour comprendre comment se
déroule cette guerre des tranchées nous
sommes rendus dans les locaux de
conspiracy W fondée en 2007 par Rudy
Reichstadt l'Observatoire du
conspirationnisme repère et déconstruit
les théories du complot et les rumeurs
[Musique]
apporte de manière répétée des preuves
selon lesquelles les enfants
c'est une c'est une vidéo de Thierry
casasnovas qui est un youtubeur
[Musique]
crudivoriste naturopathe mais qui en
fait
est une figure majeure de la couple
sphère anti-vexinale la plus radical il
y a toujours eu effectivement c'est
c'est de se faire c'est un discours de
défiance anti-vexinal avec des
motivations
diverses et puis une complot sephère
très très structurée qui délire sur des
complots mondiaux etc
effectivement c'est de se faire tente à
se rapprocher presque à fusionner
pourquoi parce qu'on a de la part des
complotistes des gens qui veulent
élargir leur auditoire et qui se servent
cette question très polémique très
sensible aussi de la vaccination pour
gagner en influence et de l'autre côté
on a des gens qui sont des activistes
anti-vaccination et qui sont amenés à
aller sur le terrain du complotisme
parce qu'il voit bien que ça fonctionne
que ça marche que le complotisme c'est
une ressource discursive en fait c'est
plus facile de jouer sur les peurs et
sur des peurs irrationnelles plutôt que
sur la raison sur des arguments qui en
plus en faveur de la vaccination peuvent
être assez contre-intuitifs donc
d'éventuels conséquences négatives de la
vaccination sont plus difficiles à
assumer que les conséquences négatives
du fait de ne pas se vacciner de
l'abstention vaccinale le problème c'est
que là on est face à une maladie qui tue
là où la manipulation commence c'est
lorsque des acteurs des entrepreneurs de
politisation vont s'emparer ces rumeurs
pour les amplifier pour les enrichir
pour les alimenter et pour s'en servir
comme d'une arme rhétorique ou d'un
discours pour ramener à eux vers leur
cause et bien de nouvelles personnes
pour faire des recrues on a toute une
économie du conspirationnisme et y
compris du conspirationnisme
anti-vexinal qui se met en place
comment ça se révolter à dire mais allez
vacciner que personne âgées
aussi
à savoir s'ils étaient efficace tout
toxiques donc en fait on est en plein
dans le plein d'enfants contrairement au
vaccin où ils sont pas capables de dire
si vos vaccins ils vont vous protéger
pendant 6 mois au moins l'immunité
naturelle elle vous protège pendant 6
mois plus de 6 mois jusqu'à 17 ans c'est
ce qu'on a vu sur d'autres virus dans le
monde des antivax les virus apparaissent
souvent bien moins dangereux que les
vaccins eux-mêmes les théories les plus
folles se propage
a été inventé pour
10h et esclavagez le reste qui survit
mais réveillez-vous et tout va très vite
les fake news se diffusent huit fois
plus rapidement que les vrais
informations comment parviennent-elles à
convaincre les hésitants en s'immiscant
progressivement dans les esprits
principes fondamental de la psychologie
humaine qui est la version au risque et
la version au risque elle génère en fait
une espèce de soif de réponse aux
questions qu'on peut se poser et
progressivement en fait on va avoir un
glissement ce qu'on appelle l'effet
grenouille dans l'eau chaude si vous
mettez une grenouille dans de l'eau
bouillante elle va tout de suite
ressortir par contre si vous mettez une
grenouille dans de l'eau froide et que
vous montez progressivement la
température et bien elle va finir les
bouillante et bien on a à peu près ce
même processus sur le plan psychologique
ou cognitif on va nous proposer des
discours ou des tests qui nous paraît
finalement assez convaincante et
progressivement voir glissement de ces
tests qui vont dire de plus en plus
radicale et qui font qu'on finit par
croire en fait à des thèses absolument
absurdes ou ridicules à la fin sans
fondement scientifique aucun et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on observe en fait dans
les processus d'adhésion notamment au
territoire conspirationniste
pour enclencher ce processus les
anti-vax s'appuient souvent sur des
études ou des personnalités
scientifiques
on a des chercheurs qui sont associés et
ça c'est très important des médecins
alors qui sont des compagnons de route
de ces associations qui ne critiquent
qu'un vaccin en particulier ou une
substance particulière dans les vaccins
et ce sont eux qui ont une capacité à
toucher un large public déjà parce que
leurs argumentaires sont beaucoup plus
crédibles aujourd'hui la controverse
autour de de
l'efficacité de l'aluminium vous avez
des chercheurs légitimes qui publient
sur ce sujet là le résultat ne sont pas
considérés comme faisant consensus mais
il y a une controversion scientifique
autour de cela et c'est eux qui sont au
cœur de toutes les contreverses
vaccinales majeures qui ont émergé en
France depuis fin des années 90
à base d'aluminium justement c'est l'un
des chevaux de batailles du professeur
Henri Joyeux un compagnon de route de
longue date des anti-vaccins en 2015 il
demande dans une pétition l'interdiction
des adjuvants à base d'aluminium qui
l'accusent de provoquer de graves
maladies il recueillent en l'espace de
quelques jours 700 000 signatures et
même si aucune étude scientifique n'a
jamais réussi à prouver la dangerosité
de ses adjuvants il défend ses positions
dans les médias où il est régulièrement
invité et continuent ainsi d'alimenter
la défiance il vous aura imposé 11
vaccins vous en avez 8 qui contiennent
de l'aluminium et moi j'avais commencé à
repérer l'aluminium c'était quoi alors
j'ai fait une lettre sous l'aluminium
pour faire parler l'aluminium de manière
un peu humoristique en aluminium je vous
assure qu'il y a pas une seule réaction
biologique dans votre corps qui a besoin
d'aluminium radié de l'ordre des
médecins puis réintégrer il continue
aujourd'hui à donner webinaire et
conférences sur la santé et la
vaccination donc on voit bien que par
exemple des personnes comme le prof
Henri Joyeux ont vraiment prospéré sur
des sites Internet qui prônent les
médecines et les thérapies alternatives
et qui à partir de ce biais là en fait
ont réussi à toucher des personnes qui
n'étaient pas forcément antivaxants au
départ qui cherchait juste à se poser
des questions sur comment guérir telle
maladie par les plantes etc c'est
quelque chose qui est très prégnant
parce que on a pu montrer que dans les
représentations collectives en France
l'idée que la vaccination peut être
dangereuse c'est vraiment installé
durablement et massivement et ça c'est
quelque chose d'assez étonnant
aujourd'hui on a par exemple la moitié
des Français qui pensent que les vaccins
comportent des risques d'effets
secondaires graves
Wakefield qui essaie de lier la rougeole
et l'autisme le professeur joyeux qui
accuse l'adjuvant à base d'aluminium
d'être dangereux
ces visages de la sphère médiatique ne
sont pas les seuls en cause dans la
cristallisation de la défiance antibacts
elle s'installe aussi lors de
différentes crises sanitaires suite à
des maladresses de communication ou à
des prises de décision politique mal
comprise exemple avec l'hépatite B
tout commence en 1994 l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé dans les différents
pays industrialisés à conseiller une
vaccination contre l'hépatite B c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons comme
d'autres pays d'ailleurs développer
cette vaccination
cette campagne cible les nourrissons les
adultes à risque mais aussi les enfants
qui rentrent en 6ème en tout 20 millions
de Français sont vaccinés à grand
renfort de publicité
[Applaudissements]
pour éviter cette grave maladie il y a
une protection le vaccin
l'hépatite B se faire vacciner c'est
l'éviter
[Musique]
mais en 1998 une controverse médicale
sème le trouble une première étude fait
un lien entre la vaccination contre les
patine B et l'apparition de la sclérose
en plaques d'autres études montrent
qu'aucun lien est
avérémental ni épidémiologique qui
puisse nous faire penser qu'il y a une
association entre la vaccination
antipathique B les poussées de sclérose
en plaques
malgré les démentis officielles le doute
s'installe et sous les effets de la
pression exercés par les mouvements
anti-vaccins Bernard Kouchner secrétaire
d'État à la santé du gouvernement Jospin
décide de suspendre la vaccination
systématique dans les collèges nous
avons simplement repousser la
vaccination scolaire et ça n'est pas
dommageable parce que entre large de 11
ans et l'âge de 14 à 15 ans alors
franchement il peut rien arriver de
risquer en matière de contact avec
l'hépatite B cette mesure de précaution
est perçue comme un aveu du lien entre
le vaccin et l'apparition des sclérose
en plaques
l'effet sur la défiance vaccinale est
dévastateur les anti vaccins marquent
des points on n'a jamais vraiment pu
prouver épidémiologiquement les liens
entre les sclérose en plaques et le
vaccin mais c'est une idée c'est une
représentation qui perdure dans
l'opinion publique sur les vaccinations
malgré l'absence de pression
scientifiques certaines personnes qui
s'estiment victimes des faits
secondaires du vaccin porte plainte au
bout d'un marathon judiciaire de plus de
10 ans la Cour de justice européenne
finit par trancher en 2017 elle estime
que si le demandeur apporte des indices
qui permettent de conclure à l'existence
d'un défaut du vaccin et à celle d'un
lien de causalité entre ce défaut et
ladite maladie alors le juge peut lui
donner gain de cause cet arrêt ouvre
donc une porte vers l'indemnisation des
personnes qui s'estiment victimes de la
vaccination
la Cour de justice ne reconnaît
évidemment pas le lien entre sclérose en
plaques et vaccination mais les
anti-vaccins tentent de le faire croire
écrit victoire et c'est ça qui fait la
force justement de ces contrastes
vaccinales c'est que elle elles sont
grossit dans de nombreux cas dans
l'existence d'incertitude dans les
failles qui peuvent exister d'un
pharmacien parce qu'il a fallu du temps
avant de trouver les bases de données
qui permettent de faire des études
statistiques démontrant l'inexistence de
ce mécanisme là mais par contre ces
critiques et vaccins ils ont aussi forcé
à produire des nouvelles connaissances
des connaissances qui n'étaient pas
nécessairement là et d'ailleurs dans mon
cas d'améliorer les dispositifs de
pharmacophygens et c'est aussi quelque
chose qu'on oublie c'est que
historiquement la pharmacovigilance elle
a bénéficié des mobilisations critiques
des vaccins parce qu'ils ont forcé à
démontrer à mettre en place les
dispositifs qui démontrent qui démontre
l'efficacité
les affaires des vaccins ROR et de
l'hépatite B forcent les gouvernements à
mieux recenser et étudier les effets
indésirables possibles des vaccins mais
le grand public ne s'en trouve pas
rassuré pour autant ces controverses
attisent les braises de la défiance
d'autant qu'une nouvelle affaire
politique au sanitaire vient encore
renforcer la confusion
nous sommes en 2009 le virus grippal se
recombine pour créer un hybride observé
pour la première fois au Mexique le
virus dit de la grippe porcine puis H1N1
fait craindre une pandémie mondiale
l'OMS déclare le niveau d’alerte
maximale
[Musique]
H1 n'a pas circulé précédemment chez
l'homme le virus est entièrement nouveau
à ce jour près de 30 000 cas confirmés
ont été notifiés dans 74 pays
j'ai donc décidé d'élever le niveau
d'alerte à la pandémie de grippe de la
face 5 à la fascisse
les prévisions sur la létalité
présupposée du virus s'emballe la
maladie se répand rapidement au Mexique
et aux États-Unis pour faire face à
cette menace nouvelle le gouvernement
Obama déclare l'état d'urgence sanitaire
en France Roselyne Bachelot alors
ministre de la Santé décide elle aussi
de mesures préventives le 1er juillet
elle annonce que la France a acquis près
de 2 milliards de masques
puis le 15 juillet elle annonce une
commande exceptionnelle de vaccins j'ai
négocié dans un contexte que vous
connaissez de production mondiale
limitée l'acquisition de vaccins à
hauteur de 94 millions de doses avec
trois industriels
Sanofi GSK et Novartis ça représente un
milliard d'euros point de vue coût
objectif vacciner l'ensemble de la
population dans les six mois mais très
vite les industriels reconnaissent
qu'ils n'ont pas la capacité de produire
aussi vite risque d'avoir quelques mois
de retard par exemple décembre janvier
serait peut-être possible donc on
arrivera peut-être après la bataille
pour la vaccination en masse de la
population et pour éviter cette vague
épidémique qu'on risque de voir avec des
centaines de billets de cas dans notre
pays pour maintenir la campagne de
vaccination à la date prévue malgré la
pénurie de vaccins le gouvernement
décide de vacciner en priorité les
populations à risque mais le jour J
malgré un important dispositif de
vaccination de masse
personne ou presque n'était au
rendez-vous
les rumeurs autour du temps record pour
fabriquer le vaccin ont alimenté les
craintes de même que la peur des
adjuvants non je pense pas que je vais
me faire vacciner j'ai pas vraiment
confiance en vaccin et je me suis jamais
fait vacciner contre la grippe donc ça
va continuer comme ça dans les 6
millions de personnes prioritaires qui
ont été ciblées dans le premier envoi de
convocation qui a été fait on n'a pas
mis les femmes enceintes et que pour les
femmes enceintes et bien on attendra que
les vaccins sans adjuvant arrive donc
moi je suis pas femme enceinte mais je
vais quand même attendre
pour tenter de déminer la situation un
deuxième vaccin sans adjuvant sera
proposé aux personnes à risque c'est un
échec cette nouvelle décision ne fait
que renforcer les soupçons
des adjuvants jugés peu sûr un vaccin
conçu trop rapidement des effets
secondaires supposés tous les
ingrédients sont là pour illustrer la
complexité du refus vaccinal du côté de
la population et du côté politique la
difficulté d'adapter ses réponses dans
un contexte épidémique par nature
imprévisible et changeant
plus on va en faire plus la population
va se dire mais s'ils essaient de nous
convaincre autant aussi qu'ils ont des
intérêts derrière et moi on en fait plus
on délaisse le sujet et plus on laisse
s'installer les discours antivaxins et
les comportements de refus vaccinal
[Musique]
la gestion de l'épidémie de grippe H1N1
par les autorités fait l'objet de
critiques virulentes l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé est accès d'avoir
été trop à l'armiste en France Roselyne
Bachelot est auditionné par la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale un grand nombre de
parlementaires veut des explications sur
les commandes massives de vaccins
l'importance des dépenses engagées fait
aussi émerger la question des conflits
d'intérêts
on ne peut laisser insinuer que des
irrégularités pourraient venir entacher
les démarches que le gouvernement a
engagé pour assurer la protection de nos
concitoyens je suis très attaché à
l'usage raisonné de l'argent public
pourquoi le gouvernement a-t-il décidé
de commander 94 millions de doses
celles-ci représentait 1,46 doses par
habitant notre commande n'avait rien
d'extravagant était tout à fait
comparable au pays qui avait choisi la
même stratégie que la France
c'est véritablement à partir de cette
affaire que les complotistes font de
l'antivaccination un pilier de leur
rhétorique
d'autant plus que l'arrivée en France de
Youtube et Facebook en 2008 leur donne
l'opportunité de partager massivement
leurs idées
ces groupes radicaux arrivent surtout en
fait à se coaliser ce que permet les
réseaux sociaux internet c'est à ces
différentes formes de croyances un peu
radicales de se mettre en connexion les
uns avec les autres ce qui fait que on
devient à la fois incrédule quand au
septembre à la fois incrédule quand on
vaccin etc etc ce qui permet de fait de
toucher un public un peu plus large mais
on reste dans des publics spécifiques
qui sont susceptibles de croire à des
théories scientifiques et politiques
très très radicales
en France dans le courant des années
2000 moins de 10% de la population
exprimait des réticences vis-à-vis des
vaccins
après la polémique de la grippe H1N1 ce
taux s'envole à 40%
fin 2020 au début de la campagne de
vaccination contre la covid 19 on compte
de 50 à 60 % de vaccino-sceptiques même
parmi les personnes âgées pourtant les
plus touchées par la maladie comme ici
dans cette résidence pour seniors de
Saint-Maur en région parisienne ou deux
résidents sur 10 ont refusé le vaccin
je ne suis pas à 100% pour le vaccin
parce que on a on entend
des choses contradictoires non il y a
rien à faire
je prends de la journée royale
ça fait 20 ans
comme partout en France les résidents
ont été les premiers à pouvoir se faire
vacciner contre la covid-19 le
gouvernement a mis en place un
dispositif de recueil du consentement
pour éviter les résistances mais malgré
cette stratégie sans ces garantir un
choix assumé du patient cette campagne
déclenche l'offensive antivax
fin décembre 2020 Pascal chanvert comme
de nombreux autres directeurs de maisons
de retraite découvrent dans sa boîte
mail un courrier menaçant qui tente de
le dissuader de vacciner les résidents
vous êtes donc un sommet de prendre
connaissance de vous obtenir de lire à
tous les ordres loi est réglement et
maintenant de l'autorité de la
République voilà et pourront donner lieu
à des recours parlent de génocide enfin
voilà quoi on voit bien qu'il va nous
tomber
toutes les plaies d'Égypte si nous
obéissons aux lois de la République donc
là on est dans un délire total
[Musique]
alors c'est tellement excessif que qu'il
y a pas un directeur qui y croit mais
dans un premier temps quand on est à
bout et qu'on reçoit un dépôt de plainte
en tant que chef d'établissement
personnel soignant
oui ça peut faire passer un salement et
c'est pas acceptable parce que c'est
jouer sur la peur avec des directeurs
dont il faut bien mesurer que depuis un
an ils sont sur le qui-vive en
permanence ils sont épuisés comme toutes
les équipes par cette guerre contre le
coronavirus par cette volonté de
défendre au mieux les résidents et donc
leur dire au bout d'un an de bataille
qu'on va en plus les poursuivre oui
c'est méprisable et petit attention je
pique je pense qu'au fond l'objectif de
ces plaindre c'est toujours un peu le
même ressort c'est d'un stylet de la
menace
pour
faire passer des idées qui peuvent être
portées dans les médias
parmi la classe politique ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait progresser une
démocratie ce qui me fait penser que ces
idées ne sont donc pas des idées qui
relèvent du débat démocratique mais que
ce sont des manœuvres obscures pour ne
pas dire obscurantiste
la crise de la covid-19 est une
opportunité pour les antivax mais leur
manœuvre n’intimide pas pour autant ceux
qui pensent que la sortie de la pandémie
passe par le vaccin comme par exemple
ici bonjour
à l'Hôtel-Dieu de Paris où se rendent
les volontaires des essais cliniques du
vaccin Jansen
à peu près les hôpitaux n'ont pas de
difficultés à trouver bon nombre de
volontaires pour se faire injecter des
candidats vaccins Corinne participe aux
essais depuis quelques mois j'étais
contacté par téléphone on m'a demandé si
j'étais toujours consentant pour
participer aux essais cliniques j'ai dit
oui je me suis pas posé vraiment une
question enfin pour moi c'est quelque
chose que qui a coulé de source avec la
pandémie enfin j'ai vu ça comme un
devoir plutôt un acte citoyen en fin de
compte j'ai dû passer ici trois ou
quatre heures j'irai c'est contribuer à
petit échelle en tant que participant au
progrès de la médecine de la science
j'ai reçu beaucoup d'informations
sur les effets secondaires est-ce que
vous avez des choses à signaler il s'est
passé quelque chose non j'ai rien à
signaler j'ai pas de chute
le vaccin inoculé on a une période de
deux ans quelques mois on est sous
observation on a un petit questionnaire
à compléter tous les trois quatre jours
pour savoir si on a on a eu des
symptômes covid en cas de si jamais on a
un problème on sait à qui s'adresser
donc j'irai c'est rassurant
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est l'été de
mettre en place ces essais de façon très
rapide en un temps record et de
permettre de recruter des participants
et très rapidement donc on a eu
l'objectif d'atteindre avec 25000
participants inscrits et nous sommes
aujourd'hui à près de 50 000
participants
on a envie d'être on a envie de savoir
si c'est normal
je comprends
très vite les gens ont compris que la
place de la vaccination allait être
essentielle et que pour sortir de cette
crise trouver des vaccins ça serait
vraiment la solution la clé à la sortie
de cette crise plus que jamais la crise
de la covid-19 met en lumière le je
t'aime moi non plus des Français avec
les vaccins il y aurait donc deux mondes
celui des antivax bruyant et actif sur
les réseaux sociaux pront à agir et même
à menacer les directeurs d'epad de
poursuite judiciaire et un autre qui
n'hésite pas à se faire vacciner pour
faire avancer la science en laquelle il
continue de croire pour lui donner la
voix qui lui manque des anonymes ont
décidé de répondre aux antivax en allant
sur leur principal terrain de jeu les
réseaux sociaux j'ai encore posté pas
mal d'articles depuis le l'arrivée du
dernier vaccin la Johnson Johnson donc
on va on va pouvoir informer sur ce
point-là aussi
vraiment que je me décide à faire un
article sur qu'est-ce que c'est que la
biologie moléculaire nous sommes quelque
part en France dans un endroit tenu
secret c'est ici que vit Marie-Claude
mamie Vax comme on l'a nommé est l'une
des 15 membres du collectif Les vaccès
qui animent une page Facebook et un
compte Twitter du même nom où l'on
décrypte le vrai du faux et en ces temps
de covid l'actualité ne leur facilite
pas la tâche
député Europe Écologie Les Verts députés
européennes
contre le vaccin de AstraZeneca qu'elle
qualifie de vaccins OGM il faudrait
peut-être faire un article ou je pense
que là il va falloir reprendre un peu
tous les propos qu'elle tient créé en
2017 à l'occasion du passage à 11
vaccins obligatoires pour les enfants
les vacqueuses ont tous les âges et tous
les profils titulaire d'un doctorat chef
d'entreprise ou simple employé de bureau
membres habite partout en France et
communiquent donc en visioconférence
l'idée de départ des vaccès c'était de
tourner en ridicule non pas les
personnes qui tiennent des propos
antivax mais les propos qu'ils tenaient
qui sont parfois un peu risibles quoi et
donc on a fait ce choix de l'ironie de
la moquerie de voilà au tout début on a
eu une grosse corde de médecins parce
que c'était la page où il pouvait se
lâcher ça nous a apporté beaucoup de
monde et qui sont venus soit nous dire
tout le mal qui pensait sur ce qu'on
fait soit au contraire qui était là de
manière très enthousiaste mais comment
ça
pour cette raison les vagus tiennent à
garder l'anonymat et utilise un chat
comme avatar c'est l'autre chose qui
nous rapproche tous et son membre des
vagues nos chats la volonté de
l'anonymat elle a été dès la création de
la page et grand bien nous en a pris
parce que il y a quelques excités qui
traînent sur les réseaux sociaux quoi
donc on a eu deux trois menaces la mort
en messagerie privée sur la page plus on
a gagné en visibilité plus les excités
nous ont un peu dans le collimateur quoi
en ce moment les trucs récurrents qui
reviennent le plus souvent dont on se
moque le plus c'est l'éventualité que ce
vaccin contient une puce
voilà une puce qui va être sous format
nanotechnologique
et qui sera connecté aux antennes 5G
c'est vrai sinon à côté de ça les choses
qu'on va cibler oui c'est par exemple
les inquiétudes que les gens peuvent
avoir concernant l'ARN qui est présent
dans ce vaccin on sent que il y a la
volonté de faire peur aux gens
[Musique]
si certains essaient de rétablir le vrai
du faux d'autres tentent de faire
renaître le débat et de développer le
sens critique
comme les créateurs de cette chaîne
Youtube la tronche en biais
Thomas Durand nous sommes et messieurs
nous sommes un biologiste devenu
vulgarisateur scientifique c'est joli et
Vlad tapas musicologue
le duo publie chaque mois des vidéos
autour de la zététique c'est quoi l'art
du doute
d'éviter que nos intuitions et la
dissonance cognitive et les influences
extérieures ne détériorent notre
raisonnement mais ce ne sera pas facile
leur but faire des vidéos pour armer le
sens critique et apprendre à ne pas
faire de conclusion hâtives
les amateurs peut-être dû laisser en
distinguant ce qui relève de la science
et de la croyance alors suis-je dans le
cadre là on est bien
welcome
alors et là le rôle qu'on se donne parce
que version n'est rien demandé c'est de
rallye Bocher un petit peu le monde des
sciences avec le les gens normaux lambda
disposent des questions combien raisons
et qui se demandent s'ils peuvent se
fier aux experts qu'on voit dans les
médias et la réponse est papa toujours
hein notez des vaccins par exemple c'est
une très bonne chose il faut douter de
ce qu'on nous dit jusqu'à ce qu'on est
l'épreuve mais il y a une différence en
temps entre l'art du doute la diététique
et la mécanique du soupçon qu'elle
conspirationnisme parce que dès qu'on
soupçonne
soupçonné c'est supposer qu'il y a une
intention et ça on peut pas ni la
prouver ni la réfuter et donc la
première démarche qu'on doit faire
lorsqu'on va être sûr qu'on a raison
c'est aller écouter ce qu'ils disent
l'inverse de ce qu'on pense on va est-ce
que ça tient la route ou pas du tout
exemple avec cette vidéo
générique
Luc Montagny a affirmé que les vaccins
étaient probablement à l'origine de la
mort subite du nourrisson dans une
conférence avec Henri Joyeux en 2017 là
encore sans aucun élément de preuve
juste son sentiment personnel
cela a poussé une trentaine de membres
des académies de médecine et de sciences
a signé une tribune je cite nous ne
pouvons accepter d'un de nos confrères
qui l'utilise son prix Nobel pour
diffuser hors du champ de ses
compétences des messages dangereux pour
la santé trois ans après où sont les
preuves promises par Luc Montagné
toujours pas les preuves
[Musique]
la science c'est un objet collectif et
ça c'est quelque chose qui faut rappeler
un expert n'existe pas en lui-même un
expert existe en cela que c'est un
représentant du consensus scientifique
qui est la vie de tous les experts qui
vont coïncider vers un objet théorique
c'est quelqu'un qui est reconnu expert
par les autres experts absolument les
gens n'ont plus confiance dans les
politiques tout confiance dans les
journalistes il reste un petit peu cette
élite scientifique en qui on a confiance
parce que la science ça marche si on
décide que eux la parole ne va pas plus
qu'un autre alors en face on a les mêmes
gens avec les mêmes défauts les la même
corruption mais sans méthode qu'est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux
j'espère c'est un vieux que la pandémie
ne va pas éroder la confiance qu'on a
dans la parole scientifique parce que
c'est encore ce qu'on a de mieux pour
pas faire de grosses conneries à
l'échelle mondiale
mais la confiance en la parole
scientifique n'est qu'un facteur parmi
d'autres en mesure d'influencer les
intentions vaccinales
je pense qu'une première chose à noter
c'est à quel point ces intentions de
l'accination elles sont volatiles et
c'est ça qui est particulièrement
intéressant avec le contexte de la covid
on voit à quel point les intentions de
vaccination elles se construisent à
partir vendre une grande pluralité de
facteurs y compris des facteurs
de connaissances des vaccins
en pleine campagne de vaccination 80%
des Français se feront-ils vacciner pour
atteindre l'immunité de groupe rien
n'est moins sûr
rumeurs gestion politique des crises
sanitaires interprétation des données
scientifiques depuis pasteur les
Français dansent avec l'hésitation
vaccinale
[Musique]